Hello and welcome everyone. It's
December 6, 2022. We're in ActInf
Livestream number 001.01, a
numbering convention that will be
explained soon. It's a discussion on the
book "Governing Continuous Transformation:
by Bijan Khezrey. And I'll pass the Bleu.
Hi everyone. I guess that's my job is to
explain the bookstream numbering. So
this is our first bookstream. That's why
it's bookstream zero, zero, one. And
this is our first Dot-Zero contextualization
video for this bookstream series. So
each week we will present a chapter-ish,
- a chapter or so - of the book. And then
periodically we will get together for
the dot one,
dot two and so forth. Those discussion
action. So if you want to participate
either in a contextualization video or
in a discussion video, please get in
touch with us and we would love to have
you on the stream. And I'm Bleu. I've
been here before so hopefully you've
seen me before and know me by now. And
I'm an independent researcher in New
Mexico and I will pass it off to Tyler.
First time appearance, I think, in the
active Coherence Institute. So Tyler,
do you want to introduce yourself?
Yeah. Cool. Thanks for having me. This
is my first time here, active inference
lab. So I have an unusual background. I
actually dot one from an academic
background at all. A lot chaos been
about applied governance. So I actually
started as a strategy consultant working
in major correlation. More recently
gotten more into Dow governance. I
currently lead product and protocol
design for the 4K protocol. It's a
project that's connecting the physical
world to the on chain world. And I'm
also a contributor at Metagov where I
think about how we can model these
abstract formalisms about governance in
a real world setting. It's a lot of
times I think about Dow governance but
most recently it's Beren thinking about
active inference and implications for
real world settings.
Conor awesome. So we are a participatory
online lab that is communicating,
learning and practicing applied active
coherence. These are all of our media
links and we will be recording and
archiving this Livestream for future
reference. Everyone is welcome and
hopefully we will be following good
etiquette for live streams and not
arguing or talking over each other for
the duration of the bookstreams.
Okay, so this is our first book stream.
Our goal is to learn and discuss this
textbook governing Continuous
Transformation reframing the strategy
Coherence conversation. It's a 2022 book
by Bijan Kesri and this video like
always is just an introduction to some
of the ideas, not a review or a final
word at all. So we will just go through
here the sections of this bookstream
we're going to do the Bookmap and the
roadmap, some keywords, the preface,
part one and chapter one will be covered
in today's video and in the coming weeks
we will be continuum to discuss this.
So get in touch if you want to partake
in these conversations. So I guess we
introduction ourselves briefly
backwards. So if either you guys want to
maybe mention something you're excited
about or that you liked or remembered
from the book from these first sessions,
otherwise we can go on to discover it.
I think we have a lot of material.
Tyler, what are you most excited about?
Yeah. I mean, I think for me,
especially being in real world
organizations, nonprofits, a lot of
times we think of uncertainty as
something that can be wished away or
something that we're incrementally going
to solve. Like, oh, if we only were
collecting more information, we would be
in a better spot, or we had more
capabilities, we wouldn't have this
problem. But a lot of times we kind of
get very anxious about that uncertainty
rather than we're an active
infrastructure force. Energy governance,
that uncertainty is placed at the
center, and it's something you can
actually take ownership over but also be
a source of creative growth. And so I
think that's really exciting and
inspirational and really excited to be
here today. Cool. I'm excited, too, to
unify some of the concepts of active
inference with governance, which I know
a little bit about, but not very much.
And now that we're formalizing our
structure as an institutional entity in
active Inference Lab Institute, I'm
excited to learn more about governance
and how things should work.
Okay, so this book has four parts. So
we're here. We're not even in part one
yet, but we're going to go over to the
beginning of part one today. So part one
is reframing the strategy governance
conversation. Part two is about free
energy governance, and part three is a
conclusion for the book. And then there
are some interviews in Parr four, along
with acknowledgements and analog. And
this is from the Bookmap software. So
this is like our roadmap for a book.
But this Bookmap software is used in
trading. So if you guys have never seen
it, that's what these graphs are from.
So when I think about Bookmap, I always
think about that. Okay, so our roadmap
for today. So we're going to get into
the preface. There are no action
headings, so we just kind of chunked
out, like, what makes sense in terms of
the text and how it reads. So we're
going to go over a summary of FET, how
to ground firms in the framework of
active inference, strategy governance
models versus meta governance, the
triplet structure of free Energy
governance, and then realist and anti
realist in Management science. And then
just a brief intro to part one. And then
chapter one, which is pretty short
thinking, born of Curiosity, Revolt,
and change. So here is a
huge list of preorders of keywords
that we're going to get into today. And
I think Tyler is going to start us off
in section one in the preface, in the
summary of the free energy principle,
tyler is going to start us off talking
about the FEP.
Tyler. All right,
so the free energy principle, or FEP,
as we're going to be calling it, this is
John's definition that he gives in the
preface. So the FEP is a mathematical
formulation that explains from first
principles the characteristics of
biological systems that are able to
resist decay and persist over time. It
rests on the idea that all biological
systems instantiate a hierarchical,
generative model of the world and
personally minimizes its internal
entropy by minimizing free energy.
Bleu anything you want to add there?
No, I think it's best. Like, we could
take a deep dive into the FEP. There are
many live streams where that's done. So
if you want to learn more about the free
energy principle, I would just refer out
to other live streams. It's best here to
take what Bijan presents, the aspects
that he's using, and go forward from
there. Cool. And I think similarly,
we'll do a similar cursory treatment of
Markoblindas. And so Markov blanket, we
could think about it is that it's a
statistical correlation for defining the
internal versus the external. So the
definition that he gives is Markov
blanket's establish a conditional
independent between internal and
external states that renders the inside
open to the renders the inside open to
the outside, but only in a conditional
sense. So the internal states only see
the external states through the veil of
the Markov blanket. Again, huge topic.
Not going to go super into it. What's
going to add anything? Bleu no, it's
great. And there are many live streams,
really, if you want to get into probably
the Emperor's new Markov blanket. So
it's maybe where we undertake, like, a
very thorough discussion of the Markov
blanket. If you want more information
there. Cool. All right. So grounding
firms in the framework of active
inference. So here is a claim from
the book. Learning to active coherence
will determine the firm's competitive
advantage and survival in a
discontinuous and distributed world.
The more fluid the boundaries between
firm and eco niche, the more important
the definition of what constitutes a
system and how nondisciplinative
Markovian boundary preserve the firm's
integrity. I e belief systems. Our
interest is shifting away from pursuing
deterministic truth through clever
analysis towards designing entailing a
generative selforganizing model that
empowers the firm to master the shifting
cognition independencies between the
known and unknown and what lies within
and beyond its control. So there's
a lot there. So I think these next
keyword slides hopefully will unpack it
a little bit. Active inference,
which we've seen many times in active
inference lab institute, is a process
theory grounded in the free energy
principle that explains behavior,
perception, planning, and action in
terms of probabilistic coherence.
Bijan doesn't yet mention active
inference, but he talks about learning
to actively, infer which I'm going to
actively infer means active inference.
And here we see this classic action
perception loop where we have internal
states and external states separated by
a Markov blanket or a nondisciplinative
Markovian boundary, and we have sensory
input and action. And these are the ways
in which an agent can interact with this
world. Do either of you guys have
anything to add here?
Daniel.
Sure. In that foraging,
I found it really interesting when
there's increased fluidity or fuzziness
or blurriness of the engagement of the
firm with the niche or the context of
the community. In those cases, it's like
more important to have and uncertainty
oriented definition of what the thing
is. And that is what confronts every
organization today.
Yeah, interesting.
Okay, so he talked a little bit about
shifting away from deterministic truth.
And so I like Googled because I'm a
truth person, I'm weird about truth, if
you've ever listened to me talk about it
before. So deterministic truth is like
the truth. And I liked this paper.
I just googled it. What do people talk
about? What is deterministic truth? And
I found this paper approaching
deterministic and Probabilistic truth a
unified account. And in this paper,
it's a 2021 paper. So pretty new. In
this paper, they talked about the truth
itself, like the truth being either
deterministic I think about that like
hitting Abel's eye, like the truth is
the number seven. And then probabilistic
truth is more like a probability
distribution around that truth, like
hitting seven plus or minus the standard
deviation or like a probability density.
Right. And this paper talks about,
like, deterministic and probabilistic
truth like that. The truth is one of
those things. And then also there are
ways to approach it, like you're
approaching your search of the truth in
either a determinalistic or
probabilistic way. So I thought that
this was an interesting read and kind of
you are interested in delving deeper
into, like, deterministic versus
probabilistic and these theories and
approaches and truth likeness. I thought
this was a cool read. Yeah, I think.
Oh, sorry. One thing to add there is, I
think our personal ideas about what
truth are, like, whether it's
terminalistic versus a probabilistic
conception of truth really carry over
onto the organization level. And so
whatever kind of delusions you have
about your personal truth in your
personal life, a lot of times they view
the organization as like the CEO views
the organization as an extension of
their own self. And so their own
worldview gets carried over and strapped
onto the organization's worldview. And
so it's really interesting that you
could kind of frame these philosophical
Dean about truth that are often applied
at an individual level and then kind of
like, scale that up into an
organization.
Yeah, very cool. And we see that in
this generative self organizing
model. Again, this is kind of like it
was cool to just search up what is a
self organizing model. And we see
generative model a lot. We don't really
see self organizing model. We see
generative model in terms of self
organization. But a generative
selforganizing model, like, what is this
really? And so this is just from this
Stanford machine
learning cheat sheet. Supervised
learning cheat sheet. So here it says
discriminative models divide the data
space into classes by learning the
boundaries. And this is like the
different neural networks, whereas
generative models understand how the
data is embedded into the space like an
auto encoding or boltsman machine or
self organizing maps. So this is like a
self organizing model. And you can
really see here this is like a decision
boundary on the left in the
discriminative model and either it's a
cat or a dog. And on the right
there's a generative model like it's a
cat with some degree of certainty or
it's a dog with some degree of
certainty. And so you see these like
probability distributions. Like probably
it's a cat but then there's like some
fuzzy like if your data point lands like
a little bit in the red or a little bit
in the Bleu, like then it might be a cat
or it might be a dog. Maybe we don't
have enough information to tell. So I
thought that this was a cool replication
of the probabilistic truth versus
deterministic truth. Like either you're
looking for cat or dog or you're looking
for with what probability. Is this a cat
or a dog? Do you guys have anything to
add here?
Cool. Okay, so this is moving on
out of this claim into the next claim.
The firm is envisioned as an inactive,
sophisticated and resource dependent
inference machine in the form of a
generative learning model. Essentially
is a statistical model linking in
circular causality action perception,
firm resources and the unknown external
world. And I just put this active
inference loop up here again. So you
have the firm and the world. The firm
would be the agent and then you have the
resources of the firm which would be
like the internal states and then the
external world which is everything
that's not the firm. And I highlighted
these terms inactive and sophisticated
because there's a dot, two unpack here,
and I think it's kind of in the
textbook. Maybe like, you can say the
words, but unless you open them up and
look what they mean inside, look inside
of them, like, you don't have any idea
the kind of Seth that goes behind these
things. Do you guys have
anything to add there on that?
Enactivism is a position in cognitive
evidence that argues that cognition
arises through a dynamic interaction
between an acting organism and its
environment. And so these are the four
es of cognitive science or
cognition. And they're embodied,
active, extended and encultured. So
cognition is grounded in our senses and
concrete experience that's enacted means
it's goal directed action in the real
world. Extended is cognitive systems
include the tools, the devices, the
people around us, our smartphone, these
kinds of things and embedded or that's
kind of what we always refer to as
encultured. But I think that they kind
of mean the same thing. So this is
cognition is woven into culture, and
learning is done in a social concept.
So these are the embodied so when you
say the firm is active yeah, that's it.
It's good for goal directed. It's doing
goal directed action in the real world,
inactive and sophisticated,
or do you guys have anything to add
there on the Four East? Okay,
sophisticated is from this paper,
I believe, sophisticated inference by
Friston and colleagues. And we've done
sophisticated aspects of inference, I
think, on a live stream, but I don't
think we've ever done sophisticated
inference. But the aspect of inference
is like a later paper and covers this
one a lot. So sophisticated inference is
really, like, in deep time. Right here,
I'll just read the figure caption. So I
have this, like, decision tree model
picture from the paper, and it says this
schematic summarizes the accumulation of
expected free energy over past and
trajectories into the future. This can
be construed as a deep tree search where
the tree branches of reliable actions at
each point in time and the likely
outcomes consequent upon each action.
So this is 1234 time steps
here and going off. So this is like a
trajectory, the path of least action.
So we talk about the way that a
system can decide and go forward in
space. So that's what's meant by
sophisticated, I think.
Anil Seth, the purpose of introducing
these terms from cognitive evidence and
neuroscience like the four E cognition
and of this type of model, it's not
a novel idea to make a decision tree.
That's how, for examples, early chess
playing, artificial intelligences work.
It's the way that the expected free
energy can be calculated across these
different paths of consideration with
respect to a generative model that are
allowing new ways of thinking about
these kinds of deep time and nested
strategic questions.
Yeah, definitely. Okay,
so temporal thickness and counter
factual depth here in this claim,
bishop says the proposal on offer here
is that the mind comes into being when
self evidence has a temporal thickness.
Models can be thicker and thinner,
deeper or shallower, depending on how
far forward they predict, or
counterfactuals depth, how far back they
postdict. That is, whether they can
capture how things might have ended up
if they had acted differently. There is
no real reason for minds to exist. They
appear to do so simply because existence
itself is the end point of a process of
reasoning. Consciousness, I'd contend,
is nothing greater than inference about
my future. And in this this is from
Bijon's book, but he's quoting Karl
Friston 2017 paper.
So that temporal thickness goes back to
the Sophistication, which is why so here
you can see how far back you can post
it. If I had done something differently,
what could have happened? This
counterfactual reasoning and then
prediction going forward into the
future. Okay, going on to
strategy governance models versus meta
governance. All right, so I'm
kind of out of my comfort zone here. So
I might call and Tyler to help me out a
little bit. But Bijan says the common
understanding underlying entrenched
strategy governance models rather
erroneously has been that action is a
coherence of perception and therefore
strategy must be environment driven. So
I look up strategy governance model and
it gave me like, some figures and this
is one of them, and it appears to be
pretty linear, but there's not a lot of
feedback happening with the external
environment. Like there's vision, a
strategy roadmap design, and then
insights come forward to the design and
back to the vision and then there's like
a performance review. So I don't know.
Tyler, do you want to give any
additional comments here on this? Yeah,
I mean, I think something that could be
potentially confusing for people who are
maybe not coming from an academic
background is that like, a lot of times
when business leaders are thinking about
how they're going to plan for the action
of the organization to take what the
strategy looks like, they're getting
data, right? And they're having feedback
from the bottom levels of the
organization, feedback to the top
levels. And so that they're taking
information, they're creating a
perception of that and then they're
creating a strategy based on that kind
of in a linear fashion the organization
executes and at some point they reflect
back like, hey, did this work or not?
What do we do with our new information?
Right? But really what they're not
realizing in the process of that is like
in that linear flow, they're not
recognizing how they're constraining the
perceptions and actions of their
organization in a top down fashion and
allowing bottom up the information to
change how information and actions can
be changed in the future. So that kind
of cyclical nature really to understand
it's really more perceived in this
linear way of like, hey, we're going to
collect as much information as we can.
Our information is going to be
imperfect, but we're going to get better
over time rather than like, hey,
fundamentally our actions and
perceptions are constrained by the
actions we're taking right now. So it's
like just a different model for thinking
about it. It's a lot more linear and not
doesn't have that cyclical causality
baked into it. Cool. And I
think about here, it seems like it's
very like tangential, like one after
another after another after another.
Whereas like active coherence lab kind
of method, like you have to sometimes
act in order to perceive, right? Like if
you want to know whether the surface is
rough or smooth, you have to move over
the surface with your finger to
determine if it's rough or smooth. So
it's action and perception that are
happening simultaneously. And I think
that is the shift that Bijan is calling
for, as he says.
Yeah, and I think just to add a little
bit, I think a lot of times business
leaders cognitive of reality as
independent existing out there. And it's
just like a limitation of their tools
and resources to understand reality
rather than the nature of perception
itself, of being able to understand
reality. And so I think that's really
like the fundamental difference and a
lot of times people don't realize that
that's even relevant at all. And so
that's why this is fun. To talk about,
that's for sure. Why like, what is
deterministic truth? Where is that
reality? And it all kind of links
together. So Bijan goes on to say, in
fact, action upon the firm's eco niche,
akin to pointing the light torch in the
dark, determines perception. Inference
is inactive. The generative model itself
never encodes anything. It just
expresses the circular causality among
all four states. The generative models,
hence is a model of the firm's eco
niche. If not, it is no good regulator
and consequently the firm will rather
sooner than later dissipate in the face
of entropic forces. And so I included
here a different kind of strategy
governance model that's like the Dean
Startup model that's like a little bit
more action and perception happening in
a more simultaneous way. I don't know if
you ant to add anything here, Tyler.
Yeah, I think a lot of the way we talk
about like, Dean Startup model of the
Lean Start model is basically like, you
don't necessarily know what people want.
And also, it's not that you're
discovering what people want is that
you're putting ideas out there and
finding how people respond to them. And
so it's basically truth is something
that you create. You can create a new
state of the world rather than
uncovering it. So it's kind of like a
method for uncovering something that's
going to work. And a lot of times it's
kind of done couch in very fluffy and
also just like experiential terms like,
hey, this works, we've done this, we
built this company this way. But what's
interesting about Active Coherence is
that can take that very fluffy wispy
framework and apply that into a more
rigorous context. A lot of these ideas
that we're talking about now, they're
not necessarily new, especially like
startup world, but there hasn't been
great language. We're talking about it.
Cool. All right, so here's another
claim. Therefore, the firm's true
governance challenge is a matter of meta
governing its generative models as an
enacted, sophisticated and
resourcedependent belief system
exercising the entire organization,
quote the body itself in contours.
We should now start seeing a model
emerging that underwrites a form of
autopilotis I eugenization.
Effectively, it is all about casting
inferences optimization mathematically
by way of gradient descent, starting
with two essential constituents. First,
hyperpria, which is the firm's
resistance to entropy in order to
persist. And two, episomic foraging and
hypothesis testing, ie. Acting upon the
eco niche to generate leaf evidencing
data. Do you guys have any comments here
or do you want to delve into this a
little more. Daniel yeah. One
interesting usage of a term there is
that the firm's true governance
challenge is meta governance. And that's
a term that is used differently or
compatibly, but with a different focus
in metagov. And so just to kind of flesh
that out here, meta governance is
being used in the sense of
metacognition, like self reflection,
memory, anticipation, action,
planning, all of these individual level
cognitive and metacognitive processes
that we model in active inference.
Often metagov in another sense is meant
like social cognition, like
relationships amongst organizations or
amongst teams. So, like, within a team,
you have their own governance structure.
Then also there's teams of teams, and
that's a meta governance structure with
respect to the team. And then that's
very interesting because the two times
that we've seen nested models, nested
generative model models in active
inference are the metacognition models
and then the ecosystem nested models.
So it really brings integrity between
thinking about what happens, like,
within and across groups.
Cool. Thank you.
Okay, so hyper prior Bayesian,
statistics, physics. Hyperpriator is a
prior distinctions on a hyper parameter
that is on a perimeter of a prior
distinctions. As with the term hyper
parameter, the use of hyper is to
distinguish it from a prior distribution
of a parameter of the model for the
underlying system. So the
hyperparameters influence the prior
here, and the hyper parameters here
influence the parameters here. And so
it's backwards at least one step in time
in this sophisticated format.
This is a better diagnosis or
illustration. The hyper Parr goes to the
prior goes to the data. So it's just in
a previous time. Seth in some way,
anything to and here. All right,
epistemic foraging. I pulled this from
active inference and learning. This
quote. It says, Active inference lab
behavior has exploration, epistemic,
and exploitative pragmatic aspects that
are sensitive to ambiguity and risk,
respectively, where epistemic,
ambiguity, resolving behavior enables
pragmatic, reward seeking behavior and
the subsequent emergence of habits. I
just wanted to kind of point out here
that active inference has been
illustrated as, like, a balance, a way
to balance exploration and exploitation
and epistemic and pragmatic value. And
like, in business, is this, like,
knowledge and money? Is that, like,
epistemic and pragmatic value, like,
knowledge of your customers, your
clients? So I was just trying to think
of how this might translate to that
money pragmatic value is like, more
resources, and epistemic value is
more knowledge of your client base or of
the future, maybe uncertainty
introduction. Yeah, I could just give a
concrete example of that because it's
especially true in software engineering,
where that is actually framed in
explicitly these terms in growth
organizations. So if you're on a growth
team, you're like, okay, we can either
turn up the dial on this thing that's
working, we're like, okay, we know this
flow is working. This wizards, this
checkout flow is working. Let's make it
like 10% faster would be an example of
exploration where we know that's going
to work in some level, where exploration
could be something we have really no
idea. This is like a shot in the dark.
Let's figure out the minimum amount of
effort we can put out to uncover new
territory. And so this exact trade off
is very much explicitly thought of in a
lot of type organizations.
Very cool. Thank you. Yeah. So epistemic
foraging is like searching around for
epistemic, seeking out epistemic value.
Okay, so moving on to the triplet
structure of free energy governance.
Tyler, this is for you. I think so
beyond Francesco, really, there's like a
key question of governance. When you're
thinking about your organization, how do
you value the person organization? And
it's really about how you create and
update your generative models so that
the firm can survive. And he presents
this framework of thinking about it and
he calls it the triplet structure of
free energy governance. There is
structure, cognition and then
capabilities. So we'll go through each
of these in turn. All right.
Structure. So sorry, this is confusing.
That header is wrong. Just get to the
next slide.
All right. Structure. So this genre,
that connectivity emerges in flow and
language bottom up stimulating from
resource markets such as clients
Technologies, spires Another are only as
relevant and meaningful to resource
reconfiguration asset exploration as
clearly as top down predictions and
prediction models, articulated
communication, and above all programmed
to process bottom up incoming signals.
So we kind of touched on this earlier,
but a lot of times decision making
organization is very linear where like,
you have very tough you're coming with
strategy and then like, that's executed
in turn every rung of the hierarchy. A
lot of times like OKRs, if you've ever
heard of this, is like a really good
example of this. It's like objective key
results where, like, there's an
objective that the top organization
comes with and then, like, the Minions
the next run have their subsequent parts
of that tree and it kind of filters down
to the rest. Of the organization where
sometimes what's not as clearly
articulated is about the introduction
between different parts of the
hierarchical and how the different parts
of the stack have to relate to each
other. So like a really good example of
this is that this is very true in tech
companies. Tech companies collect a ton
of data and none of that data is ever
processed in a meaningful way. And so a
lot of times we'll say like, we're data
driven company, we collect all this
information, but in reality a lot of
information is trapped at the bottom
rungs of the communication. It may not
have like the political ability or also
even the technical ability to process
that in a meaningful way and bubble that
up through the organization. And a lot
of times there's a huge gap in being
able to actually process that
information and bubble it up.
Appropriately in a way that can actually
crater the organization. This is like
designing this in a really thoughtful
way is much harder than it
would seem. And even if you call
yourself a data driven organization,
there's a good chance you're not
processing data in a way that can
actually generative new top down models
later on. Anything to add there?
Virginia?
Alright, let's go to the next one.
Cognition. Alright, so cognition
embraces the environment as enacted
through relationships and interactions
constructed in our brains. Environment
is not objectively, act or independently
exists, but is revealed by a firm's
action or perceptions that those very
actions generate. In fact, the
consequences of a firm's activity
controls its eagle niche. We've already
touched on this on some of the earlier
slides, but a lot of times these firms
cognitive of external reality existing
independently of their own actions and
perceptions and then it's just like up
to them to get better tools and
information to be able to understand
that reality. Like understanding this
fog of war that they're slowly
uncovering. But they actually don't
really often understand how the world
that they're perceiving is very much
constrained by one, like how they're
structured in gathering information and
perceiving that information into real
insights, then also the actions that
they're able to take. So to make it a
little bit more concrete, you can say
this very much applies in a real sense
on a website where if you're not
collecting information on views on your
page in a very basic level, it's really
hard to generate actual information out
of that, right? And so you have to
basically make a decision of like, this
is the information we want to gather,
this is what we care about and that's
going to structure the insights you can
Dean in the future and what you can do
with that information in a similar way.
Like if you're not putting resources out
for interacting with the world, like
creating a new department that's maybe a
little bit more exploratory, that's
going to constrain the actions you can
take in the future. So all this is
saying is that the reality doesn't exist
independent of you. It's something that
you actively perceive through your
action or perceptions.
Daniel in Bleu and, and anything there.
Is it like actively perceive or
actively. Create active sorry,
active states a better. Way of saying
it, or both. I mean, I think you have to
be actively perceiving, but I
don't know, I think it's a
rare treat when someone takes
responsibility or even like a company
takes responsibility for the reality
that they're creating. And like we see
this especially like in tech companies,
like, I don't know, Facebook and I mean,
just like a lot of the technology has
been life changing and world changing.
So like they're really actively creating
reality. Daniel yeah, this is
interesting about the revealing of the
firm's generative models through its
actions. And we've talked about that
fourfold partition with the internal
external states and then the sense and
action blanket states. So the firm has
access to sense and internal states to
some extent, but the world or others
have access to one's action and or
inference on their consequences in the
niche. And so it's a way to talk
about what the entire action perception
loop is with all of its different inward
facing and outward facing dynamics.
Yeah, just to add a little more Beren
too, there's a lot of focus on around
this idea as well and like startup
culture and so I'm a totally butcher.
There's like a Steve Jobs but I'm a
totally butcher. But something around
the lines of like if you had done a
marketing survey of people before they
made the ipod and asked them how they
want to listen to music, they wouldn't
have told you that they wanted an ipod,
they would have told you something else
that was conditioned based on their
previous experiences products. And so
the idea is that you just put something
out in the world to create an act and
that you create something in the world
and then the world responds to it. And
so there's this big idea, especially in
tech culture around reality is something
that you will into existence rather than
discover independently.
Yeah, it's interesting too to think
about especially you think about Google
Glass that came out like, I don't know,
ten years ago or something. Now probably
not that long ago, but it's been a
little while and I think now there's
like the rerelease of Google Glass or
some kind of similar product like the
just wasn't ready when the Google Glass
version came out, but we'll be ready
soon. They've wielded into existence and
it'll be that way soon.
Definitely. All right, the last one is
capabilities. So the inferring firm
is constantly optimizing belief
propagation as well as updating beliefs.
Sophistication that process of
optimizing cognition densities is only
as good as the firm's share of the world
model. So we are no longer just
interested in the actions consequences
per se, but how the actions consequences
impact ulterior beliefs. So another
way of saying this is that the firm has
to actively balance this exploiting
versus exploring. And I think
there's like a lot of again, folk wisdom
and especially in Silicon Valley culture
around this trade off. Whereas like a
lot of times we say hey, failure is good
as long as you're learning and
integrating those insights. And so
yeah, it blew anything to add? That no
good. Okay,
so realists and anti realists in
Management Science all right, so here's
a claim from Bishop management science
is equally divided along not too
dissimilar realist in the antirealist
fault lines. It is best captured by Karl
Weak 1977 when he states that
environment is located in the mind of
the actor and is imposed by him on
experience in order to make the
experience more meaningful. It seldom
dawns on organizational theorists to
look for environment inside the heads
rather than outside of them. Indeed,
the rise of cognitive lens in strategy
management and governance research has
enriched our understanding around
improving the design of strategy
governance processes, but has largely
remained constrained by the notion that
environment is something objective out
there waiting to be analyzed and adapted
too. And in the section,
Bijan talks about blitz scaling and
mentions some like examples of
this ants realist claim. So he says,
Google, Uber, Airbnb and Facebook are
the products of a fundamentally ants
realist enactment of an interaction with
their respective eco niches, powered by
unique and continuum evolving sets of
capabilities fostering actiongenerated.
Topdown bottom up prediction. Error
inclination to iteratively, optimized
their very generative models and implied
recognition posterior probabilities of
beliefs about the actions consequences
these companies redesign while they fly,
which is, in the words of Silicon Valley
veteran Reid Hoffman, equivalent to
throwing yourself off a cliff and
assembling your airplane on the way
down. Sullivan, 2016 in fact, we are
more in control than we resist to
believe. Blitz scaling has been integral
to the founding DNA of these super
outperformers. They listen to and sense
what wants to emerge. They are the
enacting designers of their very eco
niche. For these companies, strategy is
rather a matter of ex postsense making
than ex ants long term planning. It is a
matter of survival. And I just thought
that that was maybe a good example of
this ants realism thing that
he was talking about here. Do you guys
have an idea that. Kind of arose as you
Beren talking about this, is that one
interesting point about Google is that
they're also kind of famous for trying
really hard to do this, but failing to
create new products. So they have a
generative and killed like hundreds of
different new products that people
genuinely, truly loved even that were
quite innovative. And so it's kind of
interesting of how you even think about
what is trying to emerge and whether
that's best done in like a single
monolithic organization versus in a more
like decentralized distributed way.
So I don't know. There's been attention,
I've been kind of feeling throughout the
book as well. Is it that this entity is
trying to exist or needs to exist? Or is
it something that is more distributed
and decentralized, is more appropriate
in certain cases? So having loved and
lost several Google things in the past,
Google Reader or
Google App Maker, like the LowCode app
developing app development thing, I
mean, just like tons of things having
loved and lost, I wonder if this is like
epistemic exploration on the part of
Google, really.
I don't know. I feel like people come in
and like, I'm going to build this app
and Google gives them a lot of freedom
and they're like, go ahead, build the
app or build the platform or build the
thing and do the thing. And they build
it and it's great and people love it,
and then they move on and do something
else, and then nobody steps up to
support the love of this or what was
this person's child at Google. Right.
So I feel like maybe that might be a lot
of what's happening, but perhaps in this
creation and then unsupporting creation
and unsupporting, Google is continuously
generating epistemic knowledge. Right?
It's epistemic foraging and learning
about the niche and what people like and
what they will use on the grand scheme.
Well, I think that's true, but I'm not
going to make this argument, but a lot
of people have made the argument that
what they should have been doing the
whole time is exploiting because their
whole business is just ads and they're
like, just run that till you die.
That's the only thing that matters.
Your resources aren't well used here by
trying to do all these random things.
And so there is a legitimate argument,
too, of the limits to which you can
explore. Maybe I don't know, that's
probably out of scope for our discussion
today. But Daniel? Yeah. Just one short
note. The entire discussion of epistemic
and pragmatic value is motivated by
the fact that they're unified in the
free energy functions that are used to
determine perception, cognition, and
action in an integrated way. So at the
very least, conversation can be had
about adaptive changes in these
variables at different levels of the
organization in a different,
if not better way. That's very
integrated with how we think about the
world internally and built upon
neuroscience in that area, as well as
about thinking about the complex
dynamics and the relational dynamics of
the niche, which for information,
doesn't exist until you're seeking it
out and in feedback with it and
attention of your previous data in
anticipation of future data. All of
these cognitive dynamics. So the anti
heuristic doesn't need to be someone who
doesn't think like a real world exists
or anything like that. Even that's like
too deep for this current discussion.
It's just a purely pragmatic approach to
thinking about and modeling these kinds
of scenarios.
Very cool. All right, what else? Okay,
so here we are. We got through the
preface. That was the preface. And so
getting into part one of the book,
there's just a small quote which I'll
read. It says, reframing the strategy
governance conversation. The evidence
suggests that we are in the midst of an
evolutionary punctuation. We are
witnessing a mass extinction in the
corporate world in the early decades of
the 21st century. Since 2052% of the
Fortune 500, companies have either been
acquired, merged, or have declared
bankruptcy. It is estimated that 40% of
the companies in evidence today will
shutter their operations in the next ten
years. Merely following the trends of
change is not enough. Just like
organisms facing the Great Oxidation
events, organizations need to reinvent
the way they interact with the changing
world. And this is a quote from Digital.
Transformation survive and thrive in an
era of mass extinction 2019 by Siebel.
All right, chapter one. Thinking. Beren
of curiosity. Revolt and change. All
right, here's our abstract. Tyler, I'm
going to let you read this one.
All right? Environmental complexity and
velocity have the dominant monitors in
strategy. In governance research. The
underlying structure of environmental
Chang Kim become increasingly
distributed and continuous. The
disintermediating nature of information
technologies is challenging entrenched
business models as well as the logics of
organizing. Specialized top down
strategy processes are rather and clark
and less dynamically and generative
intertwined in real time with bottom up
stimuli and data emanating from field
operations in pursuit of prediction
error minimization. Matter established
logic of organizing or prevalent
corporate governance models are a match
for wholesale digital reinvention and
continuous strategic renewal. Nice and
going on, he says, in fact,
align to the Kai evolution from a
supervised to deep learning logic.
Corporate governance is challenged to
evolve from a supervised and rule based
best practices learning system to one of
unsupervised unlearning, ie. Self
communication. To survive, the firm must
be conceived as one cross hierarchically
integrated inference machine.
Organizing is generative, prediction
errors minimization. Strategy is
redefined as topdown bottom up
predictions. Processing the search for
knowledge is nourished, not nourished by
certainty. It is nourished by a radical
absence of certainty. Thinking born of
curiosity, revolt, and change. And
that's a quote from Cerritelli 2021.
All right, so one
of the core premises of the abstract is
saying, hey, the environmental
complexity and velocity have been
increasing over time and that makes it
more challenging for organizations to
survive. So what he says is
environmental complexity and velocity
have been dominant moderators and
strategy and governance research.
Indeed, the rate of change has not only
been accelerating, but the underlying
stress of change has become increasingly
distributed and distinguished. Sense of
urgency and heathle interrelating are
critical to survival in the world that
is now commonly perceived as full of
surprises. And so this is something just
by being on the inside of a lot of these
organizations, including corporations,
a lot of times it's perceived as, hey,
it's a scary world out there. We just
need to get our information better to
kind of understand what's actually
happening so we don't have any problems.
But I think that the problem is that the
world is changing so much faster than it
had been before, where, like this kind
of relentless approach of, hey, we're
just going to get more in. We're going
to gradually improve our prophecies to
wash away the uncertainty that doesn't
work as well anymore. And I think this
kind of former approach of strategy is
very much encapsulated by like Six Sigma
design. I don't know if you guys are
familiar with that. That's kind of like
a manufacturing idea of like, hey,
we're just going to slowly and
incrementally increase the precision of
our techniques and our processes because
any disturbance you have cascades across
your whole supply chain and all of your
other processes. So we just need to
figure everything out and so everything
will be perfect and we won't have any
issues. And that may be like
somewhat of an illusion that you can
tell yourself if things aren't changing
that quickly and maybe they'll work for
some constrained amount of time. But in
the Modern world, it's really hard to
have that illusion. You have to have a
different mental model of the world.
All right, move on to the less Bleu
Daniel had anything? All right, so the
second piece of this is like, yes, the
world is changing really quickly, and
that means that there's going to be more
discontinuities. And so he says our
discontinuities are fundamentally a
function of the cost of interacting with
the outer world in form of generating
and testing predictions. And so we say
it's not discontinuity. It's really
about this gap between perceiving the
world and saying, okay, how are we going
to take action? How are you going to
update our generative model accordingly?
And we're saying is that as the world
becomes more complex, changes much
faster than ever before, there are more
of these discontinuities, but also the
discontinuities are larger. There's just
more information to integrate. And so on
one level, you say, this is really
terrifying, the world's changing. What
do we do? But he also sounds this
optimistic note saying, well, yes, the
Modern world creates more
discontinuities, but it also creates
more tools for navigating business
continuum. And so the first one, he
says, is about this interpretation and
decentralization. So it's a lot easier
to aggregate data and process that
information and have backup plans in
case plan A fails, you have plans B
through Z instead. The other aspect of
this is AI, and so it's a lot easier to
process bigger and deeper sets of data.
And so he's trying to sound this
optimistic note that, hey, not all is
lost. There is a way to update through
this uncertainty.
I just have to say I love this meme as
someone who's tried to organize and
restructure my life probably, I don't
know, 500,000 times at this point. It's
like, do I just do the work or do I
spend time agonizing about how to
document and structure and time plan my
day into five minute blocks?
I invest so much time in some method,
right? And then I'm just like, okay,
well, I methodized it, and then I never
used the method. I just go back to doing
the work. So it's like the weird, like
all this time analyzing or dumping it
into moderating my efficiency is like
wasting my efficiency.
To connect that to the earlier
discussion about the two senses of meta,
this time cost associated with strategy
and with consequences. In the real
world, that time cost can be understood
as a cognitive cost and something
internal that's happening.
Metacognitive. How should I decide how
to decide how to perceive this. Some of
those are variables and knobs you can
understand and change. Other ones are
really subliminal. And then also that
time cost strategy nexus of course
exists for organizations and teams and
all of these nested and complex
interactions. So we want to use active
inference as and generative principle
because it helps us connect what's
happening on either side of the Markov
blanket, which might be like a data set
pass between two areas of a community or
of an communication. Understanding how
the emission model and the reception
model work together. Yeah.
To DAG that a little more is that like
I've been a product analyst at a couple
of different startups, and you actually
see this in a real way where sometimes
you can get an okay answer by just
taking a super simple average
of a couple of different categories. Or
you could try to do something really
clever and create like and ML model or
something over to predict something.
And a lot of times the predictive power
you gain doesn't match the time cost of
that. And by the time you created this
really sophisticated like publishable
model, the world has fundamentally
changed so much that your model doesn't
matter anymore. And so you're very time
bounded in how you can even use the
information you gather and the results
you glean. So for example even if you
have like a checkout flow and you say oh
yeah, like with this button the checkout
flow is 10% more effective than with
this button it will very likely be the
Chang Kim six months. The context of
that check out flow chaos changed so
much that it's actually just kind of
meaningless information and so like the
time boundedness of the information you
collect and the perceptions you can form
of that matter a lot.
All right, so the inference machine so
to survive the firm must become one
cross hierarchical integrated inference
machine that continuously builds
predictions which are gain to be bottom
of challenge. And so I think this
very much aligns with what we talked
about before like agile methodology just
kind of lean start the method of
rebuild, see if it worked you
kind of like integrate those perceptions
and learn from it. Use that to ideate
and something that is a creative act
into the world not necessarily something
that is fully informed by data and then
you build and act on it.
And he uses this quote a few times both
in the premise I think he actually opens
the book with this he says this is a
Carlovel quote the search for knowledge
is not nourished by certainty is
nourished by radical absence of
certainty thinking born of curiosity,
revolt and change. So this is
actually very important because I've
actually encountered this attention very
often in a lot of organizations where
like a lot of organizations want to be
data driven and they don't actually
another way to say, this is this is the
best product advice that was ever given.
It was from CEO of my last company, he
Sajid. There's two types of product
work. There's art and there's science.
And the science work is like, hey, we
know this works. We know we can speed up
this checkout flow and it might get
incrementally better. We kind of can
just keep going on. It's like the
exploit path. But then there's art,
which is really just not informed by the
data. And a lot of times organizations
have trouble with this because it is
truly a creative act and they're not
comfortable taking that leap of faith.
And that's really what you have to do to
do anything meaningful. And a lot of
people are much more comfortable in the
exploit path, which is a lot easier to
sell to your bosses. It's a lot more
comfortable. And you have to really very
consciously create a culture within your
firm that the explore path is even okay
and something that can be rewarded.
All right, anything that you guys want
to add here before we go? Next slide.
All right, so something
I found that was interesting with
reading this preface and the first
chapter is, like, a lot of the themes
are kind of emerging in a less technical
framework and also kind of like
pseudospiritual ideas about business
management. And so this is like a quote
that was from the paper or from the
book. It says that firms are called to
open up all four channels of listening,
listen to what you know, what surprises
you from the whole and what
you sense wants to emerge the emerging
home. Right? And so if we kind of think
about integrating information across
different levels of the hierarchy like
John was talking about, you can think
about that from a more, like, rigorous
academic perspective. But there's like a
lot of other books, especially that come
over the last five years that are
conceiving the organization allostat
like a pseudospiritual lens where it's
conceiving the organization not as the
extension of the CEO's ego, but really
as this entity that needs to be nurtured
and cultivated and understood on its own
terms. One of the most famous books
about this is called Reinventing
Organizations. And Reinventing
Organizations introduced the idea of
kill organizations. These are like
nonhierarchical heterogeneous
organizations. So in that book, he says,
instead of trying to predict and control
the future, members of the organization
are invited to listen in and understand
what the organization wants to become,
what purpose it wants to serve, which,
like, on first reading, that can feel
very, like, pseudospiritual and kind of
like hand wavy. There's actually a very
real thing that can actually be modeled
in a more rigorous way with active
coherence. I think that's really
exciting. Another way that this has been
talked about has been in bronze. J.
Robertson's book Callocracy Holocracy is
another similar to organizations, is a
nonhierarchical form of governance.
So he says each tension human being sent
the signpost telling us how the
organization could evolve to better
express its purpose.
All right, anything you guys want to and
in. Conor.
So I don't know, anything else that you
guys want to add. Just thanks for being
here and going over this stuff with me.
And is there anything else you're
looking forward to or what's next?
I'm really excited. Just logistically,
how is the series going to continue?
Sure. So we'll finish one chapter a
week is the goal, maybe like we're
trying to still work out the logistics
of the holiday, but I think it looks
consistent. So one chapter of the book
per week, something about that,
something like along those lines, and
then a discussion after each section of
the book. So there's part one, part two,
part three, and we will get in touch
with the author and see maybe if he is
willing to come and discuss some of
these ideas with us and hopefully we'll
have other people that want to
participate in the discussions of the
work.
Tyler and then I'll give a thought.
Yeah. I think the thing I'm looking
forward to is so far we've been excited
about is that putting a concrete
framework behind ideas that have so far
been expressed in very abstract kind of
hand, lazy terms across different kind
of startup folklore and kind of business
type business books. And so I'm curious
as the next step about Hohwy, it can
become a little more like tangible and
practical for someone who is in the
perspective of being in an organization,
how do you actually design an
organization to embody free energy
governance? And so I'm really excited
to see how that can become a little more
concrete and clear. Cool. The part
I'm looking forward to is continuing to
explore that Explore exploit dialectic.
Both of those in the extreme lead to
failure in some way or at least increase
risk. And so this frames are
strategizing as being like in some sort
of landscape with explore and exploit,
which of course is really complex with
these nested organizations. And then you
brought in the art and science, or
science and engineering or just art and
communication or whatever other
dialectic. And then even within an
artist's day there's realities like
accounting and the mixing of the paint
and even the prompt engineering for
someone who's using those kinds of
artistic forms. So it lets there be sort
of a light and adaptive
quote explore explore scenario
happening within the concept of
something that's a lot more meaningful,
which is the integration of like art,
science, personal meaning, collective
meaning and so on, without denying that
those kinds of Explore exploit attention
and strategic dynamics must happen also.
Cool. Well, thanks for participating
guys, and we'll see you next time.